[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau 7,8 l'hebdo tout de
suite les titres de ce vendredi 22 mars
vingt ans que face yvelines agit contre
l'exclusion toute l'équipe était réuni
hier à versailles bilan à suivre de ces
deux décennies des classes surchargées
une détérioration de l'apprentissage en
accompagnement personnalisé sacrifier ou
encore projet de loi de jean michel
blanquer air contestées nous ferons
point sur la situation avec deux
représentants de la sphère éducative
semaine de mobilisation zoom sur l'école
française des femmes mais aussi
découvert de la 98e édition de la foire
de chatou comme chaque vendredi coup
d'oeil sur l'actualité de la semaine
le club d'entreprises face yvelines à 20
ans depuis 1999 la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion développe des actions autour
de deux axes et l'éducation et l'emploi
toute l'équipe était réuni hier à
versailles pour faire le bilan de ces
deux décennies
or élire 11 étaient sur place
l'équipe 2 face yvelines réunis pour
célébrer les 20 ans du club
d'entreprises avec ses actions de job
academy de graines d'entreprises ou de
manteaux ring la fondation accompagne
depuis 1999 les acteurs économiques dans
leur engagement sociétal pour un avenir
sans exclusion une philosophie qui n'a
pas changé depuis deux décennies
on cherche à faire que les gens qui sont
dans le trou c'est à dire les gens qui
ont des difficultés à trouver un emploi
retrouve l'énergie nécessaire pour
retrouver eux-mêmes un emploi et on
essaie de faire que les jeunes qui sont
dans les quartiers défavorisés
réussissent à avoir un projet
professionnel en vantant le bilan est
positif une centaine de partenaires
impliqués
dix mille personnes ont été accompagnées
par la structure parmi elles s'en tient
en décembre 2017 nous l'avions suivi
lors d'une opération de manteaux ring au
collège gustave courbet de trappe alors
élève en 3e elle avait pu découvrir
l'univers de l'entreprise thalès et
consolider son projet d'orientation
g
amélioré à noël parce que c'est pas
vraiment quelque chose où je suis à
l'aise et comme je faire du journalisme
je pense que c'est un point fort les
tuteurs continue à suivre ses élèves
tout au long de l'année et on espère
bien pouvoir poursuivre ce partenariat
avec le collège et le club fasse pour
voir l'avenir un petit peu plus loin et
essayer de continuer cette action qui
est bénéfique pour tout le monde
objectif de faciliter pour les
prochaines années continuer à développer
ses actions sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi dans le
nord de notre département
c'est un chiffre qui sonne un peu comme
une surprise le 19 mars 24 % des
professeurs des écoles étaient en grève
selon le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
41% selon le snuipp-75 à majoritaire
dans le premier degré qui annoncée des
taux de grévistes allant jusqu'à 70 %
dans certains départements un taux
inédit dans les écoles depuis 2010 est
avec nous en plateau pour en parler à
nuuk bertin bonjour vous êtes
enseignante de français au collège de la
géo à elancourt est également en
bertrand mesure qu'au secrétaire
départemental de la sn une ip pfs eu
yvelines
alors ce mardi 19 mars était aussi la
journée mondiale du travail social
pourquoi avoir rejoint le mouvement
ça ne paraissait essentiel de passer
notre message à ce moment là voilà nous
faisons partie donc des fonctionnaires
d'état et notre jeunesse était en péril
donc ça collait bien avec le mouvement
social
oui manifestement la loi bancaire ainsi
que la loi de transformation de la
fonction publique sont des lois qui sont
des boîtes à outils qui permettent de
casser le service public en général et
le service public d'éducation en
particulier et de renforcer le caractère
très inégalitaire déjà de l'école
française pour créer des parcours
scolaires à plusieurs vitesses alors
justement on va revenir sur vos
revendications avec cette mobilisation
suivie dans les yvelines notamment dans
le collège de la jure ou 80 % des
titulaires
on fait grève notamment pour dénoncer la
baisse de la dotation horaire le nombre
d'heures allouées pour l'an prochain en
diminution
ce qui entraîne selon les grévistes des
classes surchargées une détérioration de
l'apprentissage un accompagnement
personnalisé sacrifiés quelle est la
situation actuelle au sein de votre
établissement je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur de français au collège de la
géo à elancourt et bien nous avons pour
l'instant une classe de 6e à 30 donc
nous pouvons voir si les effectifs
montent dans les autres niveaux ce qui
est prévu voilà ce qui va se produire
c'est à dire que nous avons des sixièmes
à 30 et qu'il est très compliqué pour
eux d'acquérir des méthodologies pour
les apprentissages que l'on a du mal à
différencier nos méthodes
d'apprentissage pour que chacun puisse
s'y retrouver
nous avons un collège avec une grande
hétérogénéité et donc des élèves
dyslexiques des élèves avec porteurs de
handicap et des élèves précoces
donc nous voulons apporter un soin à
chacun et à 30 c'est très positif
alors derrière cette mobilisation la
contestation il y a un projet de loi
pour une école de confiance de jean
michel blanquer a adopté par l'assemblée
nationale c'est un empilement de 26
articles et 1000 amendements alors je
vous ai fait un peu un résumé et parmi
ces articles j'en ai sélectionné quatre
je vais vous demander de réagir
brièvement le premier article 9 de
l'évaluation
donc cette évaluation de la politique
éducative confié à un conseil
d'évaluation de l'école dont 10 des 14
membres seront choisis par le ministre
cette loi remplace le snec qu
institution indépendante mise en place
également d'autoévaluation
d'établissement et d'écoles
qu'en pensez vous écoutez ça s'inscrit
dans là dans la continuité ce qui s'est
fait depuis les années 2010 puisque au
delà du cne ce qu il faut savoir aussi
que la plupart des rapports des
inspecteurs généraux ne sont plus
publiés
c'est de l'ordre de 80% de ces rapports
qui ne sont publiés alors qu'auparavant
le
proportion était inverse en termes de
publications il ya clairement depuis une
dizaine d'années et en particulier
depuis que jean michel blanquer air est
arrivé au ministère puisqu'il avait déjà
des responsabilités à cette époque la
volonté de mettre le secret sur ce qui
se passe au sein du système éducatif et
de faire en sorte que les politiques qui
sont menées ne soit pas évalués à leur
juste mesure
une réaction concernant cet article ce
qui est dommage c'est qu'on nous demande
une différenciation pédagogique et que
l'évaluation globale donc c'est un peu
contraire cette évaluation différencier
le projet de loi prévoit également
d'abaisser l'instruction obligatoire de
six à trois ans je me tourne vers vous
bertrand mesure bah écoutez clairement
ça pose deux problèmes le premier c'est
que un c'est un financement de l'école
privée à hauteur de minimum 150 millions
d'euros de charges supplémentaires pour
les collectivités locales qui même s'ils
sont compensées par l'état son ca - qui
va vers l'école publique
d'autre part on sait très bien que sur
les territoires où l'école publique
n'est pas en mesure d'assurer cette
scolarité à trois ans comme par exemple
en guyane ou à mayotte
le ministère ne mettra pas les moyens
permettant de l'assuré donc c'est
clairement un cadeau qui est fait à
l'école privée et en plus l'obligation
d'accueil à 3 ans va entraîner des
contraintes aussi sur un certain nombre
de communes qui vont avoir à financer
des dortoirs supplémentaires etc et tout
ça se fait sans aucune étude d'impact la
loi de jean michel blanquer air propose
un pré recrutement par amy et les
surveillants qu'en pensez vous je pense
que ça dévalorise notre profession
puisque il me semble que ce sont des
surveillants à bac + 2 et que on nous
demande d'avoir le concours
donc voilà je ça veut dire qu'on peut
mettre n'importe quelle personne devant
les élèves pour enseigner et ça me
dérange beaucoup s'inscrit aussi dans
l'après courait que précarisation prévu
au travers de la loi bancaire et des
différents articles sur
l'expérimentation et puis aussi
sur la loi de refondation de la fonction
publique qui prévoit de faire des
recrutements massifs de contractuels et
même si on n'est pas tout à fait dans le
même registre s'inscrit vraiment dans
cette précarisation autre article le 1 b
drapeaux tricolore et européen paroles
de la marseillaise obligatoire en classe
une bonne mesure
je n'ai pas vraiment de commentaire à
faire sur cette mesure je trouve qu'il
ya beaucoup d'autres choses essentielles
à voir avant d'appliquer cette mesure
je dirais que effectivement les médias
malheureusement se sont beaucoup
concentrés sur cette mesure là est sûre
par un parent 2 alors que la réalité de
cette loi c'est une réalité comme je le
disais de mise en place de système
éducatif très différents et à
différentes vitesses et la volonté de
casser l'école française
je pense que effectivement c'est
anecdotique sa manifeste de la dérive
réactionnaire et droitière de ce
gouvernement mais c'est pas l'essentiel
de la loi et c'est pas ce qui nous
inquiète le plus il y à des
manifestations prévues samedi 30 mars
rassemblant l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative enseignants et parents que
comptez vous faire
il va falloir qu'on se consultent avec
les parents d'élèves les représentants
des parents d'élèves pour voir si un
continent le mouvement et vous en tant
que représente
nous avons d'ores et déjà appelé
l'ensemble des collègues à s'informer à
informer les parents des réunions avec
les parents sont organisées un peu
partout sur tout le territoire des
yvelines
je rappellerai que les yvelines était
entre 50 et 60% de grévistes dans le
premier degré les collègues sont
extrêmement inquiets ils reçoivent pour
l'instant un retour extrêmement
favorable des parents qui eux aussi sont
inquiets face à ce qui s'annonce et ce
qui s'annonce je le répète encore sans
aucune étude d'impact c'est à dire qu'on
a mis en place une loi qui va
complètement changer le système scolaire
français sans qu'il y ait eu aucune
étude en amont et sans qu'il y ait eu la
volonté politique de la firme et tout se
passe dans le dos des citoyens tout se
passe dans le dos des collègues et c'est
inacceptable
on passe tout de suite au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
coup de projecteur sur une structure qui
permet d'apprendre aux femmes étrangères
à mieux maîtriser la langue de molière
après six établissements dans les
hauts-de-seine une septième écoles
françaises des femmes a ouvert les
portes en janvier dernier et dans les
yvelines et plus précisément à mantes la
jolie
ce dispositif unique en france a fêté au
château de versailles c'est dix années
d'existence et dispositifs que nous fait
découvrir aurélie rose
ambiance studieuse dans cette salle de
classe un peu particulière nous sommes
au centre de vie sociale aimé césaire à
mantes la jolie
depuis le début de l'année une vingtaine
de femmes viennent plusieurs fois par
semaine perfectionner leur français au
sein de l'école française des femmes
fondée en 2008 par l'institut des
hauts-de-seine il s'agit du premier
établissement yvelinois vous proposons
du français langue étrangère ce n'est
pas de la halle travesti dation donc ce
sont des femmes qui sont allées à
l'école et qu'ils sont diplômés dans
leur pays d'origine
donc elles ont acquis les automatismes
de l'apprentissage à la différence de
l'alphabétisation ou là les femmes pour
la plupart ne sont pas allés à l'école
l'adhésion est de 15 euros pour une
année scolaire
après un test de niveau les femmes sont
répartis en plusieurs groupes pour un
meilleur apprentissage et doivent
s'engager à suivre minimum quatre heures
de cours par semaine
en fin d'année si elles le souhaitent
elles peuvent passer un diplôme d'état
le delf diplôme d'étude de langue
française
dinet ben les oubliera ont toutes les
deux un projet professionnel et
souhaitait également mieux s'intégrer
quelqu'un qui arrive à qui n'arrive pas
se comprendre certaines choses barbares
là aussi on est comme une équipe
j'ai envie d'apprendre et écrire à mieux
parler sa tigresse tout simplement et
c'est très très bien
au lieu de rester qu'à la maison il faut
faut donner du temps pour soi
émancipation évolution sociale et
professionnelle
voici les valeurs portées par l'institut
des hauts-de-seine qui avait choisi le
château de versailles pour fêter ses dix
années d'existence
au total plus de 2000 femmes issues de
65 nationalités différentes ont pu
bénéficier de ce programme éducatif
unique en france
une idée qui a particulièrement séduit
le département des yvelines
l'idée c'est de pouvoir peut-être aussi
le développer sur d'autres quartiers
prioritaires
au delà de mantes-la-jolie sachant que
sur mantes la jolie c'est aussi un
ancrage sur le mantois
non c'est la première année des chéneaux
à mantes la jolie
on savait pas qu'il ya autant de monde
comme ça voici la première fois ça me
rend une visite franchement je trouve ce
merveilleuse c'est bien fatma ainsi que
les 400 femmes inscrits dans les
différentes structures ont pu bénéficier
d'une visite guidée du château de
versailles
l'année dernière son % des apprenantes
qui ont passé le diplôme d'étude de
langues françaises l'ont obtenu en tant
que professeur de français une petite
réaction par rapport à ce reportage
oui c'est une très belle initiative et
puis voilà ça développe d'autres
l'autonomie des femmes donc forcément je
trouve ça très très bien la france
mesure que pensez vous du travail en
éducation prioritaire sur sur trappe
donc il existe effectivement d'autres
structures d'alphabétisation et qui
permettent aux femmes de 2,2 d'apprendre
à lire et à écrire pour certaines
d'entre elles parce qu'elles n'ont pas
eu cette chance dans leur pays
c'est aussi un élément indispensable
pour que les enfants puissent s'inscrire
ont des parcours scolaires parce que ça
donne du sens à ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire à l'école et on le sait bien
entendu c'est aussi ce qui permet
d'améliorer la situation économique et
sociale de l'ensemble de la famille
puisqu'on sait que plus le taux
d'alphabétisation et le niveau d'études
est important chez les femmes est
meilleur la situation sociale d'un pays
est cette semaine c'était le coup
d'envoi de la 9e édition de la semaine
de l'industrie
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie s'est rendu sur le site
d'airbus défence n space à elancourt
objectif de cette semaine donner un coup
de projecteur sur cette filière et faire
découvrir les opportunités
professionnelles aux lycéens et
collégiens auraient lire 11 et patrick
jacques de dixmude des lycéens de saint
quentin en yvelines venu en apprendre
plus sur l'entreprise airbus defence and
space sur ce site implanté à elancourt
des ingénieurs travaillent notamment sur
la cybersécurité ou encore
l'électronique de défense
on
nouvelle révolution industrielle qui est
devant nous qui est l'utilisation de
logiciels l'utilisation du big data
l'utilisation d'une machine learning de
l'insouciance un ciel tout ça dans de la
production qu'on pourrait imaginer
pourtant classique et ça c'est l'usiné
du futur une industrie qui se renouvelle
et qui offre de nombreuses opportunités
d'emploi selon la secrétaire d'état ni
espagne et une hache et 50000 emplois ne
seraient pas pourvus dans ce secteur les
français ne savent pas exactement ce
qu'est leur industrie on imagine
beaucoup comme germinal des métiers
pénibles des métiers qui paye mal des
métiers qui vont disparaître alors que
c'est tout le contraire
ce sont des métiers qui paye 20 % de
plus que l'ensemble des autres secteurs
ce sont des métiers qui sont durables ce
sont des métiers qui ont du sens les
visiteurs d'un jour ont pu découvrir les
ateliers ainsi que les équipements
électroniques spatiaux même si toutes et
tous ne se destine pas forcément à une
carrière dans cette entreprise
ils ont été impressionnés pour moi
c'était une entreprise même pas avec
e.on telle ampleur et beaucoup de monde
qu'en pense notre message aujourd'hui
était de leur faire comprendre que
c'était ouvert à tous que ce n'est pas
forcément que des ingénieurs qui
viennent travailler chez nous et qu'il
ya de la place pour tous les jeunes et
que les métiers scientifiques ne sont
pas si compliqué que ça
la semaine de l'industrie se poursuit
jusqu'au 24 mars avec l'ambition de
susciter de nouvelles vocations
la semaine de l'industrie l'occasion
pour les collégiens et lycéens de
visiter des entreprises
ne faudrait-il pas renforcer l'éducation
sur le monde des entreprises auprès des
lycéens et collégiens
ah oui ce serait une bonne idée si on
avait beaucoup d'heures consacrées à la
fin puisque pour eux ça c'est assez
abstrait je parle notamment au niveau du
collège et que effectivement ça peut
leur donner des pistes de réflexion pour
leur orientation
une mesure dès le plus jeune âge
peut-être bah écoutez moi je serais
tenté de dire que c'est bien de montrer
des secteurs de pointe la société et
puis les
et les éléments dits productif par les
économistes néolibéraux mais il faut pas
oublier non plus qu'une société vie de
beaucoup d'autres métiers et que en
particulier tous les métiers qui sont
assurées essentiellement par des femmes
sont des métiers qui sont extrêmement
précarisés mal payés mal reconnue alors
que je ne vois pas comment une société
peut continuer à exister et y compris
dans ces éléments technologiques les
plus pointues s'il n'y a pas derrière
des personnes pour assurer l'entretien
s'il n'y a pas des personnes pour
assurer alors on parle beaucoup en ce
moment des ehpad on parle beaucoup en ce
moment de l'hôpital et tous ces secteurs
là qui sont des secteurs qui sont
essentiellement portée par les services
qui sont énormément porté par les
services publics sont des sociétés des
secteurs dans lesquels il ya de plus en
plus de précarité et des salaires tout à
fait indigne
donc je crois que c'est bien de
promouvoir la haute technologie
mais c'est bien aussi de promouvoir ce
qui fait l'essentiel d'une société c'est
à dire le lien quotidien et la vie
quotidienne
je pense qu'on ne peut pas se contenter
de se dire qu'une société ne vit que de
la haute technicité
merci bertrand mesure je le rappelle
vous êtes le co secrétaire départemental
du snuipp-fsu suivent lille merci à nous
bertand je le rappelle vous êtes
enseignante de français au collège de
l'avion à willencourt merci à mr d'être
venu et cette semaine
autre mobilisation avec les agents du
secteur de l'action sociale du conseil
départemental des yvelines
une manifestation dans le cadre de la
journée mondiale du travail social ce
mardi et 19 mars
plusieurs revendications notamment sur
le manque de moyens et d'effectifs dans
le cadre des missions d'accompagnement
social et de protection de l'enfance
reportage de relire 11 ils étaient une
centaine d'agents du conseil
départemental des yvelines des
travailleurs sociaux manifestants devant
l'hôtel du département ce mardi 19 mars
à l'appel de la cgt de la fédération
autonome de la fonction publique
territoriale
leurs principales revendications la
baisse des moyens budgétaires alloués au
secteur de l'action sociale des yvelines
le constat c'est qu'en fait on nous
alourdit la charge de train
et en créant de nouvelles missions des
nouvelles missions avec lesquels on
pourrait être d'accord on réorganise
l'accueil on réorganise l'enfance la
santé l'insertion et le travail social
mais à chaque fois c'est sans moyens et
avec des missions complémentaires
nous on peut pas mener la même qualité
de service et quand on est aux prises
avec des personnes des familles qui sont
surendettés en procédure d'expulsion de
la violence conjugale
on a une charge mentale lourd absorber
pour mener à bien son travail et on se
dit bon bah maintenant j'ai plus que 20
minutes pour gérer ce que je faisais en
1h30 quoi assistant social éducateurs
spécialisés ou encore conseillers en
économie sociale et familiale les postes
occupés par ces agents dans les centres
de protection maternelle et infantile ou
de planification d'éducation familiale
leur mission accompagner les publics en
difficulté nous demandons aux
départements davantage de moyens de
changer sa politique de réduction des
effectifs de réductions budgétaires
en considérant que la priorité d'une
collectivité départementale doit être de
consacrer son effort et notamment son
effort financier à destination des
familles pour les plus en difficulté
sollicité le conseil départemental n'a
pas donné suite à notre demande
d'interview
ce dimanche se clôturent la 98e édition
de la foire de chatou sur l'île des
impressionnistes
l'occasion de découvrir plus de 200
exposants
c'est la plus grande brocante de france
la 98e fois international de chatou est
installé depuis le 15 mars sur l'île des
impressionnistes
chaque année près de trente mille
curieux déambule dans ses allées c'est
une foire qui permet aux
visiteurs de chine et des objets de 1
euro ax
on peut y trouver aussi bien de petits
objets que des antiquités digne de
musées parmi les 500 exposants présents
benoît moreau fête cette année sa
huitième participation à cette foire se
passionnés de brocante restaure des
meubles anciens
on a beaucoup de meubles comme ça c'est
les mêmes que l'on trouvait dans les
administrations milieu du xxème siècle
que l'on aime transformer complètement
pour les réadapter que qu'on puisse les
utiliser dans un intérieur beaucoup plus
contemporain
voilà les rendre un peu plus sexy un peu
plus attractif et on les modifie pour
après leur donner une vraie utilité si
vous êtes plutôt bijoux anciens la
spécialiste claudette picard propose
depuis 20 ans sa sélection sur la foire
la brocanteuse coche ce rendez-vous dans
son agenda plusieurs mois al avance à la
une ambiance qu'on trouve nulle part
ailleurs
c'est festif c'est convivial tout le
monde
tout le monde est heureux de participer
je pense à cette foire et les clients
sont ravis de venir passer une journée
quand il fait beau
enfin même quand il pleut pour découvrir
ces trésors sous le soleil ou sous la
pluie vous avez jusqu'à ce dimanche 24
mars la perle rare se trouve peut-être
au détour d'une allée
nous passons à notre rubrique ça s'est
passé comme chaque vendredi au retour
sur l'actualité à travers nos archives
et il y a tout juste 19 ans le début du
printemps était marquée au château de
versailles par le début d'une campagne
de replantation au lendemain de la
tempête lothar
[Musique]
c'est en ce premier jour de printemps
que le château de versailles tourner
enfin la page de la tempête un jeune
tulipier de virginie a été replanté
aujourd'hui identique à celui rapporté
au xviiie siècle par le général la
fayette est abattu en décembre dernier
par les intempéries
un tulipier qui prendra racine au même
emplacement une cérémonie volontairement
symbolique autour de l'amitié
franco-américaine
les américains sont terriblement attaché
à versailles et dès qu'il y a eu cette
tempête j'étais aux états unis au moment
de la tempête c'était extraordinaire la
solidarité
quatre élèves de l'école de fayetteville
en géorgie qui a financé l'achat de cet
arbre était présente aux côtés d'une
représentante de la maison blanche et
d'une entreprise américaine mécène de
l'opération qui offre 100 arbres au parc
de versailles
c'est vraiment fantastique dans cinq ans
qu'un jeu pourrait venir ici avec mes
petits enfants et leur dire quand
j'avais votre âge et planter cet arbre à
versailles c'est vraiment magnifique
l'europe a déjà été américaine a offert
une centaine d'arbres notamment des
essences rares qu'il ya des armes qui
étaient donc qui avait terme importés à
l'origine par vieira lafayette raté les
venues ici qui ont été détruites
la campagne de restauration du parc de
versailles a donc commencé chacun peut à
son tour parrainer un arbre et aider au
reboisement
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo vous
pouvez retrouver l'émission en replay
sur notre site internet
retour de l'information lundi à 18h dans
le 7-8 journal d'ici là passez un
excellent week end
[Musique]